quency estimations with without
predictions hi everyone thanks for
staying late into lunch break um so this
is Joy with anest Justin H and Ali and
they're all in the audience so if you
have questions please ask them don't ask
me H so the main tilder of this work is
can we get better frequency estimation
algorithm under some natural assumptions
and before I talk about the assumptions
I need to give you some background first
so frequency estimation is kind of like
the bread and butter of
streaming algorithms you know it paid a
lot of bills let's just say uh so what
is the problem um we're given a large
data stream of numbers from one through
n let's say and we see you know 8 17 222
and so on and at the end of the day we
want to sort of keep track of um how
many times every element appear for
example how many times did off four
appear in our list of numbers and we
want to do this in uh sublinear space so
of course if we use space n we can keep
track of every number you know know how
however many times four appear exactly
but sort of the interesting case is when
we when we restrict ourselves to using
sublinear space much smaller than the
the universe size and even this is sort
of an idealized problem that appears in
a lot of settings but also it's a good
test beted for uh streaming and uh
sketching algorithms in general so a lot
of you know like very nice techniques
were deed for this
problem okay so now let me yeah and uh
please feel free to stop me anytime so
now let me introduce the heroes of this
talk which are assumptions you know they
make the problem a lot
easier so the first assumption that
we're going to be working under is this
learning augmented model meaning we have
access to uh some prior some information
about the stream that we're going to
process in particular the assumption is
going to be we're going to have access
to heavy hitter predictions I'll be more
precise about that in a bit but
essentially we're going to assume that
we kind of have a rough sense of which
elements appear a lot of times in the
Stream when then you know when if
element five arrives we kind of know
that it's going to appear a lot of times
and we're also going to kind of work
with this other assumption that the true
frequency distribution is heavy tail
meaning roughly like it follows some
sort of a power law and this is not that
unnatural of an assumption for example
for many books right the distribution of
word counts is power law and you know
for many natural distributions this is
also the case okay and I'll get in get
into how these assumptions sort of play
with each other on the top so I need to
give additional a little bit more
background first so what is the story so
far with these assumptions and um the
frequency estimation problem well there
was a very very nice
work uh there was a very very nice work
by uh Su IND kabian um Ali and
essentially what they said was uh we
could take um an existing frequency
estimation algorithm like count sketch
or cman and you could augmented with a
with a model of with a with some
predictions that just gave you these
heavy hitter predictions essentially it
worked in a very clean manner like you
know a stream element comes if it's
heavy we kind of keep it aside and keep
track of it uh uh explicitly and if it's
not heavy then we kind of feed it into
an existing streaming algorithm like
count sketch or
count and the the short and sweet
intuition of why this actually helps and
this is a very simple idea but it's very
powerful is that a lot of these
streaming a lot of these sketching
algorithms for frequency estimation what
they do is they take the universe and
they sort of compress it into a much
smaller space and you can think of it as
mapping the domain to a much smaller
domain and essentially for an element if
another element sort of collides with
you and if it has really large true
frequency then that's really going to
mess you up so if somehow you could sort
of figure out which elements are heavy
and keep them to the side that will
really help with the overall
error and and and to show like why this
helps they analyze it under this zifan
distribution so that's where this
assumption comes into play and
essentially we can think of the I
largest frequency is roughly
proportional to one over I but although
like there techniques and you know
artwork they it can generalize to other
sort of models but let's uh stick to
this for now and they Analyze This
Behavior under a natural predic a
natural aerometric meaning um
essentially if the tillers are our
predictions we kind of want better pred
or we kind of want better estimates for
larger frequencies so this was the um
aetric study it's a little different
than sort of standard error metrics
that's usually used which is this you
know worst you know pointwise error but
this this is also kind of an interesting
um error metric that we might care
about okay so now let me tell you like
ah you know this predictions this what
does it all lead to like concretely does
it um improve our um algorithms or our
performance so um if we sort of say okay
whatever count Min right it's some
standard uh streaming algorithm for
frequency estimation I'm not going to
get into what it does but essentially if
we say okay it has error one under this
metric like this error metric whatever
that
means how well does this learn approach
that I showed you before where you sort
of allocate a separate bucket to heavy
elements how well does that do it sort
of does as well it sort of does this it
performance is this um so how can we um
in um interpret this it essentially says
that if the space is B and if B is very
large then we actually get a big um
improvement over this regular version
that doesn't use any predictions so I'm
sort of normalizing the error so that
count minut is one and the Learned
version that I showed you before uh gets
this okay so that's this is all prior
work so
far so there are some kind of
interesting next type of questions right
like for for example we can see here
that we only get like uh mathematically
we only get an advantage if the space
used by the algorithm is very large
right this term is is going to be
smaller than one only if B is very
large and so that's a little weird right
like we assumed heavy we assumed zian
distribution and we assume we have
access to predictions but like
theoretically we can only show a big
Advantage if we use a lot of space so
there's something you know that doesn't
feel quite right
[Music]
um but there are sort of more uh meta
questions that's interest that are
interesting which is right if we assume
that our stream is Zan in the first
place can we just get better algorithms
without any predictions in the first
without any access to predictions or
like are there better ways to use
predictions rather than these this like
allocation scheme where we uh we
allocate separate space to heavy
elements so these were the questions
that we were interested in this work
okay so so now let me tell you about
some uh new and interest or new and
additionally interesting results so
first what we did was we said okay to
understand if we can do better than you
know these uh this simple but very
powerful way to augment traditional uh
uh sketching methods for frequency
estimation we first have to understand
like how old they do exactly right so
the so one of our contributions is to
sort of tightly characterize the
performance ments of these classical
count sketch and count main
algorithms that that that were proposed
by prior
works and kind of something very
interesting uh is that for both this
learned uh count Min version and learned
count sketch version it it it turns out
that these learn versions are only uh
useful or uh theoretically useful or
theoretically I know they only
theoretically outperform these prior
versions if the space use is very large
which but in you know typically in
frequency estimation right we want the
space to be much smaller than n so that
was kind of
interesting so that was that's one of
our uh contributions and then
the the second interesting contribution
is we actually introduce a slightly
different algorithm that that is a
little that is much different or that
sort of goes beyond these like
traditional count sketch and count
mbased methods that actually does uh
much
better so we have some new algorithm
called new algorithm you know
essentially like I said it doesn't
matter what these numbers are it's just
relative performance to each other we
can see that like our new algorithm with
some B words of space it actually does
better than the Learned version of count
sketch in some regimes without ever
using any heavy hitter predictions at
all and if we um additionally use
predictions for our new algorithm we get
even better
performance so yeah like I said it
doesn't matter what these
uh what these numbers are just that you
know we want this to be as small as
possible and we introduce a new
algorithm that sort of outperforms these
prior methods and it really sort of
exploits this zian assumption and the
fact that we have a
predictions so before I tell you about
the algorithm you know how it works is
everyone okay with the setup so far yeah
and please feel free to ask any
questions
[Applause]
okay so you can just like forget about
everything that I've talked so far uh
talked so far about and I'll just um
yeah let me quickly mention that this
this zian distribution is not that
uncommon right like there have been a
lot of Prior theoretical and practical
works that consider it and it makes
sense right and a lot of real world
distributions might
be okay all right so
um
okay so now let me tell you about our
new frequency estimation um on the
algorithm and how it works so the whole
idea can be sort of summarized in one
drawing so you know this purple line is
let's say is the true frequency
distribution right and I'm plotting it
in some sorted order so you know we have
some frequencies that are very big but a
lot of them are very small and this blue
dotted line is sort of the additive
error of classical streaming algorithms
like count
sketch
so the idea is like okay if we know that
com sketch or whatever classical
frequency SM algorithm already has a
large additive error right there's no
reason to pay this addtive error for a
lot of elements in particular right in
this graph right if we know for these
small frequencies right the the addtive
error totally um overwhelms the actual
frequency right so why would we pay this
large thing when we can just pay this
thing so so the whole idea is to to say
okay for these small elements it's
actually better to predict them at zero
because that gives you a smaller error
then pay whatever the prior um
algorithms give
you but uh but the problem is right like
this is sort of an idealized setting
where we know all the
frequencies um I'm I'm a priority like
we don't know which elements have small
frequencies and which which have large
frequencies so so the so the whole idea
is okay um we want to say okay if
something is small we want to predict
this we want to out we want to estimate
at zero but we don't know which
frequencies are small so so what can we
do um so it's a very uh simple idea but
I think it's pretty fun and the idea is
okay can we use the estimate of count
sketch itself to determine if something
is small or
large
so so we have some frequency estimation
Al them like count sketch if we say okay
what is the frequency of element number
65 and it says it's very small then it's
likely that um or you know it says that
it's about the same value as the addtive
error that's getting then it's likely
that it's a small El right so we should
be actually correcting it to be zero
instead of sort of accepting the uh the
error of count
sketch
um and it turns out that for a lot of uh
frequencies like for example zian stuff
the addtive err count is actually a
known quantity so we can kind of assume
that we know what this blue line Looks
like even though we might not know what
the purple curve looks
[Applause]
like yeah so this is sort of the
idealized algorthm that we want to do
right we have you know we we just use an
regular count sketch algor the stream
and then when we want to estimate
frequencies we we ask count count sketch
itself if it's if the if it estimates
something as large or small if it says
okay if con says okay the frequency is
kind of large then let's all listen to
it if it says it's small then let's
output zero okay so this this makes
sense but uh there is one problem which
is that it could be that some very large
frequency is is uh estimated to be small
and then we actually make it even
smaller by outputting zero so we could
uh suffer a really big uh
error
[Applause]
um so how do we uh get around this and
so far like our algorithm doesn't use
any predictions at all it's just trying
to really exploit this zian assumption
to get a better frequency estimation
algorithm so you know whenever we have
like this problem of uh you know um a
noisy estimate right in algorithms we
just take many independent copies so
that's kind of what we do we we in in
our frequency estimation algorithm we
actually have a ton of very small count
sketches and you can see like there's a
log log n factor and essentially we have
log log and copies of very small count
sketch tables and they're gon to
actually help us refine our estimate so
that this this idealized procedure of
you know outputting zero or listening to
count sketch actually works and and we
also have one giant count sketch table
that's going to be the thing that we
listen to at the
end
okay right so like I said the the idea
that we're going for is that we want the
estimate of the smaller noisy tables to
determine if we should either listen to
the large table or just output zero at
the
end
so that's so our whole algorithm can be
summarized like this right you know we
keep track of a bunch of count sketch
tables some of them are very small one
is very large and when we want to
estimate a frequency value we just ask
all these small tables if they to if
together they say the value is large we
listen to the final large count table if
together they say it's small we output
zero and that's the entire query
algorithm right um I'm not going to tell
you what the threshold of large and
small is it's a little technical but the
um the idea this goes back to that
drawing I uh showed you
before that's what you want to do and
this is the the entire um algorithm we
have a bunch of small sketches and we
use them in conjunction with each other
to determine if we should actually
listen to them or just output zero
um
okay all right so now uh and the
learning augmented version right like
where does that come in so far I haven't
talked about predictions at all it's
very simple we actually use the same
framework of firework we have our new
algorithm now instead of using count
sketch or count Min here and we just
take a learn Oracle that gives us
predictions and we say if something is
heavy we store it to the side if
something is not heavy we plug it into
our new algorithm that I just
described
um yeah so before I give you like the
sort of math behind why it works let me
show you some quick experiments and
these are experiments on two real world
data sets that have where you can learn
some predictions and they follow roughly
some power law Behavior one is like um
the internet packet data the other is um
uh search
data it doesn't really matter what the
X's are just that you know like our our
line is is much closer to zero than the
um other line so it's actually an
implementable algorithm that that works
very
well yeah
so okay so now let me tell you why it
works and so I was feeling a little
nervous so I included this slide so I
can
stretch
okay okay all right all right cool so
now why does this simple um idea work
like I said this is the um
algorithm right so let's go back to this
drawing right this is like the whole
motivation for this work right the ideal
analysis is that for large frequencies
we're okay paying an addtive error of
some algorithm but for small frequencies
we want to pay zero that's what we
that's the goal
um but the error turns out to be a bit
um um
asymmetric and in particular right like
if this whole idealized framework goes
wrong for small elements then that's not
so bad because at the end of the day you
know we're we still have this final
table that we're leaning on right even
though we want to Output zero we might
output some other number but but that's
okay because even if you know something
goes wrong at the end of the day we just
pay the count sketch error using for the
final
table and essentially you know we have
log log and small tables so the
probability of that this fails you know
it's roughly one over log n and so it
doesn't really matter what this math is
that that's kind of why we gain some log
n factors in our
bound but the real um issue that I
talked about before is for large
elements if for large elements if
somehow you know this process ends up
outputting zero then that's a huge error
that we have to pay right so we have to
show that the probability that this
happens is very
small um but the point is that a large
element is only going to be you know we
only output zero for a large element if
it looks small to all the small data
structures that we have in particular
like every estimate of the small or many
of the estimates of the small Thea
structures have to be very very off for
for us to think that a large element is
a small
element so essentially we just bound the
probability that you know every small
ele every you know smaller data
structure deviates a lot and the uh and
this um analysis is kind of nice so I'll
give you a high level idea of how it
goes essentially we say
okay uh what is the probability that uh
you know that for a small you know one
of the small uh data sees that we have
that it deviates a lot well we can
introduce two events the first event
seems kind of um arbitrary so we're
going to introduce a parameter okay for
our estimate to be really off either
like you know another large element has
to collide with us right but there
aren't that many of them because we have
this zifan
assumption if a small if a large element
doesn't collide with us then the other
event has to happen what is the other
event a lot of many many small elements
have to collide with us but you know uh
the probability that so many things
collide with us in our in our account
sketch table right we're we're hashing
you know probability of collision is
small
and the probability that a lot of things
Collide is very small um so this is just
a very very high level idea of how we
sort of get this deviation
bound but the nice thing that um that
happens is that um the probability that
any of our small
estimates deviates by such a large
amount actually perfectly cancels with
the the amount of deviation like the the
probability and the the quantity
multiplied to be very small which is
nice um so that's that's a very very
rough uh sketch of why things work out
for the small elements um these M uh
these log log end tables sort of boost
the probability of us making a mistake
and if even if we make a mistake it's
not so bad for the large elements you
know making a mistake is a big big deal
but to make a mistake we have to deviate
a lot and the probability of this
deviation is very
small
um yeah I guess yeah that's exactly 3
o'cl that's when I wanted to end um yeah
I think there's some really interesting
open questions like for example in our
work we really exploited this zun
assumption to get better algorithms are
there better ways to exploit this
assumption and we use predictions in a
very very blackbox manner like we just
set aside heavy elements and then use
our other algorithm for not heavy
elements are there better ways to use um
predictions and just the more meta
questions is like meta question is um
can we get better learning augmented
algorithms for other interesting
problems oops Yeah and I guess I want to
say that our algorithm also kind of
works for IFI or non zian uh we have
some worst case guarantees for non- zian
data but yeah zian is where it really
shines yeah so that's that's all I have
to say happy to take any questions in
any questions
person um why didn't you consider Mis or
gree
uh um I guess like even in the non uh
learning augmented world uh these count
sketch and count M algorithms have
better performance than GRE
because miso gree doesn't have the large
element issue in fact it's even uh the
larger the power law or the more severe
the power law the better for M of grees
now it doesn't it it doesn't track the
taale so it it doesn't give you counts
of very small values but is that the
difference I mean
what P will answer that
question yeah so uh as in author of the
prior work on which this improved yeah
so so basically we looked at algorithms
which allow both insertions and dels
right so this uh this includes uh uh
basically hashing based algorithms right
but uh MRE doesn't allow doesn't give
you
dysfunctionality
I this said that said you know it's it's
a very good question if you can make MRA
gas even better using uh predictions
it's an excellent question actually
[Applause]
any other
questions so when I often hear about
learning predictions I feel like it's a
um I'm given a prediction and it might
be good if it is good then I do this if
it's not as good then I recover the
worst case performance is that the sort
of flavor here or is this like a
different kind of like learning of
predictions structure it's kind of the
same flavor like we're using predictions
in a very blackbox way we're just saying
if we're if we think something is heavy
we can just keep it to the side
otherwise we plug it into any other
existing algorithm and the whole point
of this work is that this algorithm part
that we plug into we can improve it a
little bit more um so like for instance
uh if you're given just like really bad
side advice which just says that every
element is likely right right so this
still has worst case guarantees because
right like things we keep explicitly
things that we explicitly track okay
well we have we we track them explicit
we get zero error and the the algorithm
that we're relying on right already has
worst case guarantees even without
prediction so so you do get some worst
Cas guarantees but so you might lose
some space like you your guarantees
might be a little bit worse than if you
didn't keep track of something
explicitly but you you still have
something to uh fall back on right okay
maybe could you specify like what what
is the shape of the side information in
this case like is it possible for the
side information to tell you like
literally every element from one to n is
should be like counted should be
considered heavy yeah so here I guess
when we um analyze it under this let me
get go back to the table I guess when
we're um analyzing sort of this
performance we're assuming the
predictions are perfectly correct like
it perfectly identifies things and this
is a good idealized assumption because
um I guess you know I guess the proof of
why it works is that like in practice
when predictions are not so so good for
example um in the sort of in the
empirical results that we have you know
predictions are not okay I can't find
the predictions are not perfect it still
works very well so it's still a good
test bet to design algorithms
around so do you need to assume that uh
like you you you get the exact threshold
or or can you leave with like a constant
Factor uh error uh we can live with
constant factors lot L end factors are
kind of floating around so we can live
with that right right so if if if you if
you can uh leave with a constant Factor
uh threshold then basically the results
go through right it's just yeah okay all
right okay so for the interest of time
we just take the rest of the questions
offline let's thank sanip again and
today we have a very short break
so so today we have a very short break